LIBERAL, MERCEDES LAP.
HE IS SO DAPPER, HIS POCKET
SQUARES HAS A POCKET SQUARE.
I'M NOT KIDDING THIS TIME, THAT
IS PURE SEERSUCKER.
HOST OF MAKING MONEY, CHARLES
PAYNE.
YOU MAY RECOGNIZE HIM FROM
CARING ROB SANDERS LUGGAGE.
ACTOR, AND NO DEAR, FINALLY, SH
IS LIKE A SHELL CASING, TINY,
BRASSY, AND OFTEN FIND AT CRIME
SCENES, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
KAT TIMPF.
CHARLES, WELCOME TO THE SHOW.
FUCHSIA OR PURPLE TIES FRISKY
WHEN IT COMES TO COLOR THEY
INVENT NEW ONES ALL THE TIME, I
DON'T KNOW.
IT'S IN THE PURPLE FAMILY I
GUESS.
>> APPARENTLY WE SHOULD HAVE
CALLED EARLIER AND WORK THIS
THING OUT FREIGHT I FEEL LIKE
AND MAY BE AMONG CUTE AS I HAVE
BEEN WRONG IN THE PAST RARELY.
I FEEL LIKE THERE'S AN IMPLICIT
AGREEMENT BETWEEN POLITICIANS,
PEOPLE OF POWER AND PERPETRATOR
FREIGHT YOU KEEP IT TO YOURSELF
AND YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS AND
WE WILL LOOK THE OTHER WAY.
IN CHICAGO, AS LONG AS YOU STAT
IN THIS SITE, AND YOU DON'T COM
OVER HERE, WE'RE GOING TO
EVENTUALLY LET IT GO.
IN MY CRAZY?
>> NO, YOU'RE NOT CRAZY BRIGHT
AND CHICAGO, SOME PEOPLE SAY ON
OF THE REASONS IT'S EVEN GOT
WORSE IS BECAUSE OF
GENTRIFICATION OF THE BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE GOTTEN
SMALLER OR THE HISPANIC
NEIGHBORHOODS SO THE TURF WARS
ARE MORE INTENSIFIED.
AGAIN, THEY LOOK THE OTHER WAY.
IF YOU KNOW YOU CAN GET AWAY
WITH CERTAIN THINGS, GROWING UP
IN HARLEM, I WITNESSED MURDERS,
ATTEMPTED MURDERS, STABBINGS,
AND YOU ALWAYS KNEW SOMEONE
WOULD EITHER NOT GO TO JAIL OR
WOULD GO TO JAIL AND FOR A SHOR
PERIOD OF TIME SO THIS HAS BEEN
AROUND FOR A LONG TIME BLAMING
GUNS INSTEAD OF THE PERSON.
AT LEVEL TWO SAID ABOUT THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM BECAUSE THAT I
THE ROOT OF IT, FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING THE WATER DOWN BS
EDUCATION THAT ESSENTIALLY IS
SAYING WE THINK YOU ARE TOO DUMB
.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO PRESSURE YOU.
WE'LL READ AND JANE ALL THE WAY
TO SIX GREAT AND THE TIME YOU'R
IN 12TH GRADE IN YOUR ARE FOUR
OR FIVE GRADES BEHIND YOU WON'T
BE ABLE TO COMPETE IN SOCIETY,
BUT WE WILL GIVE YOU HOUSING
PROJECTS, WE WILL GIVE YOU MORE
FOOD STAMPS, IT IS NOT SPIRIT I
IS WORKED FOR THE DEMOCRATS FOR
DECADES, I THINK IT IS STARTING
TO FADE LITTLE BIT WITH YOUNGER
GENERATIONS.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO
SEE THROUGH THIS.
OLDER GENERATIONS ARE THAT'S WH
THEY CAN ELEVATE BIDEN BECAUSE
OF THEIR FOLKS NUMBER ONE IT WA
REALLY TOUGH.
YOUNGER PEOPLE ARE SAYING I WAN
TO START A CRYPTO MINING COMPANY
.
SO IT'S NOT WORKING LIKE IT DID
BEFORE.
>> EVENTUALLY SCHOOL IS A
HOLDING PEN FOR KIDS.
JAMIE, DO THEY HAVE CRIME IN
ALASKA, AND IS IT COMMITTED
MOSTLY BY BEARS?
>> WE HAVE A LOT OF BEER ON BEA
CRIME.
>> AS LONG AS THEY KEEP IT IN
THEIR COLONY.
>> WHO CARES.
>> IT'S WEIRD HOW DIFFERENT OUR
LAWS ARE.
EVEN LIKE CELL PHONE DRIVING
LAWS.
IN ALASKA WE HAVE A LOT THAT
STATES IF YOU'RE TALKING ON YOU
CELL PHONE, AND YOU'RE DRIVING
AND YOU SEE A POLICEMAN, YOU
HAVE TO PUT YOUR PHONE DOWN FOR
A SECOND-GRADE THAT IS THE LAW.
>> THAT IS THE LAW.
ISN'T JUST SO MUCH BAD NEWS, I
FEEL LIKE EVERY TIME I COME BAC
IT'S MORE AND MORE CRIME, IN
THESE BIG CITIES, SO MANY
MURDERS AND STUFF AND WANT TO
SEE IF ANYBODY SEES THAT IN ANY
BIG CITIES IF YOU WANT TO COME
ONTO MY SHOW I PROMISED AN
ENTIRE HOUR WERE THERE WILL BE
NO KILLING.
TO GET ALL JUST LET THAT SIT ON
THAT ONE.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED IN YOUR?
COULD YOU NOT WORRIED.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THE WEED SITUATION HERE.
YOU CAN JUST HAND OUT, IS THAT
ILLEGAL THINK THEY'RE DOING IT
AND NO ONE IS ENFORCING A?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> WHAT IS WEED?
>> GENERALLY COME OUT WE TO
CHURCH.
AND WE HELP THE KIDS.
THIS WEED BUSINESS IS NOT OUR
PURVIEW.
>> THIS IS THE TIME FOR
OURSELVES.
WE ARE SO BUSY HELPING THE KIDS.
>> IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
YOUR CRAZY POT STUFF, TAKE IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
MERCEDES, IF YOU LOOK AT HOW
LIBERAL MAYORS OUR DEALING WITH
CRIME, YOU WOULD THINK THEY ARE
ON THE KKK PAYROLL.
BASICALLY, THEY DON'T CARE THAT
BLACKS ARE KILLING EACH OTHER.
THAT IS JUST INSANE.
>> THESE LIBERAL MAYORS, IT'S
ALL ABOUT IDENTITY POLITICS FOR
THEM, BUT WITH IDENTITY POLITIC
OF TAKING DOWN THE COPS, THEIR
GOAL IS TO DEMONIZE THESE CAPS,
THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE SO MANY OF
THESE POLICE OFFICERS LEAVE,
THEIR LINE OF WORK, AND REALLY
NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE THESE
COMMUNITIES I THINK FOR THE
DEMOCRATS I DON'T GET IT BECAUS
THEY GOING TO GET CRUSHED IN TH
POLLS AND THE NEXT ELECTION
BECAUSE THE BULLS ARE SHOWING
THAT CRIME IN PUBLIC SAFETY IS
TWO OF THE TOP ISSUES RIGHT NOW.
I HOPE JAMIE IS PUTTING ON HIS
THAT KILLING IS NOT GOING TO BE
PART OF A SHOW, I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE A HELPFUL THING, BU
TO GET WORD-OF-MOUTH, NO KILLING
.
BUT, I THINK FOR THE DEMOCRATS,
IT IS DEFINITELY A BIG LOSS FOR
THEM.
REALLY, EDUCATION, IT'S ABOUT
THE FAMILY AT THE END OF THE DAY
.
THAT IS THE CORPORATE WHEN YOU
HAVE DESTABILIZED FAMILY
STRUCTURES WITH THE PARENTS OR
NOT THEY ARE OR THE CHILDREN, O
EVEN THE GIMP GRANDPARENTS, THA
AND IN AND OF ITSELF.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT FATHER OR
MOTHER, ONLY ON FATHER'S DAY CA
YOU TALK ABOUT FATHERS, AND IT
REALLY IS THE CENTERPIECE OF IT
AS WELL.
IT STARTS AT THE HOUSE TO BE
ABLE TO REALLY BUILD UP.
>> IF YOU DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE
HOUSE, THAT IS THE FIRST 4-5
YEARS.
IF YOU DON'T DO SOMETHING BEFOR
16, THEM IT'S GONE.
IF WE COULD JUST GET THEM SOONER
, BEFORE THEY ARE OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL, THAT MIGHT HELP
ERIC.
>> MAY BE GETTING THEM OUT OF
THE WOMB WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN WATCHING THE
SUPREME COURT VERY CLOSELY SINC
THE EARLY 70s.
SO THEY RULED TODAY THAT
PREVENTING SCHOOL CHOICE
FAMILIES FROM TAKING THEIR KIDS
TAXPAYER-FUNDED EDUCATION
DOLLARS TO RELIGIOUS PRIVATE
SCHOOLS VIOLATED THE FREE
EXERCISE CLAUSE OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
>> OF COURSE IT DOES.
SEE I COULD BE A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE.
YOU'RE LUCKY TO HAVE ME SITTING
HERE WHEN I COULD BE ON THE
BENCH.
>> I THINK ALL THESE PEOPLE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO TRY THAT HARD
TO LEARN FROM THEIR MISTAKES
WHICH SAYS TO ME THEY MUST BE
TRYING TO NOT LEARN BECAUSE YOU
JUST HAVE TO PAY A LITTLE BIT O
ATTENTION TO NOTICES OF WORKING
BECAUSE THIS AS FAILING.
YOU ALSO NEED TO HOLD CRIMINALS
ACCOUNTABLE.
REALIZE THE PROPERTY CRIMES ARE
NOT VICTIMLESS.
IN REALIZE THAT VIOLENT
CRIMINALS ARE NOT THE TYPES OF
PEOPLE WHO DESERVE LENIENCY.
APPARENTLY THAT IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO THEM TO THEN
BLOODSHED ON THIS STREET WHICH
THINK I DO HAVE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES.
>> I AM ANTI- BLOODSHED.
>> AND NO INTEREST IN THIS THIN
CALLED WEED.
>> NO.
>> JAMIE, WHY DO YOU BRING THIS
POISON AND STALKING PIXIE.
>> IT'S IT IS INSULTING TO TALK
ABOUT THAT IN FRONT OF A LADY
SUCH AS VIBRANT A GUY DON'T KNO
IF THE PANDEMIC HIT ANYBODY ELS
I GAINED A LITTLE BIT OF WEIGHT
I DID EDIBLES EVERY NIGHT FOR
TWO YEARS.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, IT WASN'T
JUST WEED, IT WAS JUST THINGS
THAT WE'RE EDIBLE.
>>